Hello everybody! My name is Markplier  and welcome to Fishy.
Now a lot of you guys out there have asked me very personally to play Feed and Grow,
which is a game where you play as a fish or a shark or any other sort of ocean creature
and then you eat EVERY other THING in the ocean and you imbibe them in your body and you absorb their
nutrients and somehow you grow bigger from that?
But in order for me to play that game I have to go back and play Fishy, which is a game that I have talked about
when I play Agar.io, uh, Slither.io, uh, Tasty Planet. I've talked about this game
UHahOHho
My ears! What the Fuck?!
Shut up!
Oh my God that just exploded my ear drums.
Okay.
So this is Fishy and Fishy is basically the same game as thus I just described.
You are a tiny little fishy!
You're kind of the smallest fish in the entire pond, but your objective is to eat and DEVOUR
AND ABSORB
(creepy voice) The other fishes in the ocean...
and hopefully don't touch any fish that's bigger than you because everything is trying to eat everything.
Now- What the (spit flying) FUCK
Oh come back! I LOVE YOU!
Ohh Shhiit
Now the thing about this game is-(Burps)
UHuhOkay
Now the thing about this game is I played this. This came out in 2003. I was just at the cusp
of hitting Puberty for the first time. My voice cracks quite a bit now so I'm not sure I ever got through it...
I played this so long ago that I can't exactly remember where I was the first time that I played it,
but it's a really cool game in that the simplicity of it kinda lends to making it a more interesting experience.
And- *Markiplier Noises*
Okay
Aah! Okay, never mind, rebounding off the top.
Ooh, this is getting a bit deadly.
So basically, it's a game
of patience. You have to
wait... for the right
fish, to come across your path
and then make the mistake
of ever saying hi to you.
Because you're a horrible fish
that just reaps... destruction
everywhere you go.
In the beginning it's very slow because obviously
you have to wait for your prey to approach you
and you have to make sure that
tHEY'RE OF THE RIGHT SIZE
Ooh, that guy wanted to come across. I apologize
my voice is a little raw,
uh, for no other reason than I was screaming
a lot yesterday--I wasn't recording
or anything, I, I just like to stand on my rooftop
and tell my neighbors how awesome I am.
In case they didn't notice from all the other times
that I've, I've screamed
in videos and left the window open.
Um, but basically what I was doing yesterday
is, I was playing a game
and, I won't say what game it is
because I'm still going to play it again but I spent
an HOUR recording it,
like, SUPER high energy
it was a fun, engaging game,
...  (screaming) AND THEN
THE RECORDING BLEW UP
FOR NOOO FUCKING REASON
other than the universe wanted
to say "Fuck you, Markiplier,"
"You're an asshole."
Anyway... But...that's what I was doing yesterday.
So it was a lot of fun and just utter disappointment
And then I ate my feelings in
potato chips and french onion dip
You can tell this is a true story
because of the specificity of how I covered up my shame
(laughing) with potato chips...
I hadn't even..  I hadn't even, like
I've been trying to eat healthy for a long time
but I was so pissed off
that I actually went to the store exclusively to buy
junk food for me to eat
which, I'm sure it's something that you guys have
NEVER EVER DONE before
when you have something go wrong in your life
but for you, it's probably something important,
for me, it's just.. (giggling) my recording went bad
and I wasted a lot of energy and my voice hurts
(stuttering) Also the day jus- Th- The day just before um...
I- I- I put out a vlog yesterday that was basically
telling you guys that there was this um
Warcraft thing that we were doing..
Uh, I- It's in promotion of the movie "Warcraft" that's coming out because
I'm a big fan of World of Warcraft
I've been playing it.. on and off since it first came out, but
I- I love the game a lot and they got, like
30 Youtubers together in one place
Youtubers and Viners, and a whole bunch
of other people. A lot of people that I met for the first time there
which was REALLY cool
Um... in one place, for us to play
a full-length game of Capture the Flag
in real life. So we had these, like, powdered balls -
- You'll see the video when it first comes out
They actually didn't give me an authentic release date
for when that was gonna happen
But they told me it was gonna be relatively soon
So expect that video- I'll let you know
when it's coming out
I don't know if it's gonna be on my channel,
it might be on a different channel, so..
But it's gonna be AWESOME
because the game, uh, was super fun
it was VERY very like, like ah
physically demanding
I mean I've been getting in shape, I've been doing a lot
of exercise recently, but this was just
taxing to a completely different degree because
we ah.. wh- what happened was we played -
- well I don't even know if I should talk about that -
- but we played a whole bunch. We played for a long time
because they were obviously filming it
and they wanted to make sure they got all the right shots and whatnot
so, uh, w- we were playing- OoH God
Ohh jeezums that was close
- We were playing it for a long time
uh, but it wasn't fake or staged: any of the playing
so we legitimately had to play over and over again
Which was fine, it was totally fine, I don't mind that at all
but we had to play for like an hour and a half straight
of just non-stop pro-dodging
and basically being a BADASS that I am (sure, Mark...)
in the face of adversity
and the Horde.
I was team captain for the Alliance
which was really weird considering my red hair, but
IT'S FINE, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT IT'S COOL
So the finished product will be available, ah, soon-ish
probably some time before the movie comes out
I'm not 100% on when that'll be,
but I will let you guys know..
This is getting a bit dicier
for some reason, I don't know why.
I think it's because I'm bigger
so basically the margin of error for me to..
miss other creatures that are bigger than me
has shrunk down tremendously
and I ca- I need to concentrate now because I could actually get screwed over at any moment
and.. shit
See I don't know what kinda freakish creature exists
I really hope it doesn't actually exist - Ooh
that's- I think I coulda eaten that guy but I'm not gonna risk it, I'm playing it safe here because
It takes a LOONG time
to be able to climb back onto the top of the- woah
This was a bad move, that was a BAD move
that was a very- oh God, this..
WOAH
If like a FAST fish had come across just at that moment
I would've been sooo screwed- woah
That guy picked up speed right towards the end...
Waahhhhh -ok
Wuh
it's the FAST ONES THAT SNEAK UP ON YOU
THEY JUST WANNA GET MY STEEEEZ (?)
I'm gonna get them eventually
They're gonna knooow what true pain iiis
*More Markiplier Noises*
ok. Yes, aw man, that could've been a sweeping strike
I wasted my opportunity
I'M NOT GOOD ENOOOUUUGHHH
oh God
eh...
I think I'm playing it too safe actually
Nah, I'm probably playing it just safe-
JUST SAFE ENOUGH
Just exactly the level of safe that I desire
Yeah, I knew I could eat those guuuys
I knew I COULD
GET IN MY MOUTH- NOM
*mouth noises*
No one use that out of context, please. (( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
Wooh shit
Wooh- good move, good- UGHH
WOOH-OK good move good-
WOOAHHH
good move, good move, good move. Good move
I like how I'm patting myself on the back
No one else here is gonna celebrate my victories, so I gotta be the one that..
Really really make sure that I
circle-jerk myself (what a lovely graphic image, Mark)
nice..
oh God.. Don't get trapped
Wooh shit
Oh Shit. OH shit.
OH Shit. AHH shit.
WOAH that was dangerous
goin' up on the edge of the screen like that, that was almost death
Ohh man
I am shocked that I made it outta that one alive
Oooh God
ooOOOHH GOD DON'T LOSE IT
OOH GOD IT'S OK
Ohh, everything's fine (x3)
Everything's fiiiiiine!
I'm almost to the point where I can easily claim victory
because once you reach a certain size, you just start eating
aaabsolutely everything!
And that's good
Okay, good
good
good good good
oooOOOH
I think I coulda eaten that guy
That would've been a close call though, so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna risk it just yet
Not just yet, not just yet
You...
Yes...
I think you...
No, I'm not gonna-
WAOUH
AWW FUCK YOU MAN!
FUCK OFF!
Ohh, come on!
Oh, fuck that!
DAMMIT!!
CURSE YOU FISHY!!! (I hope his window isn't open)
Alright, I'm back in
Good job, me!
Well done, me!
You did a great job, me!
Oh thanks, me! *chuckle*
I really appreciate it!
And by the way, can I say that me looks pretty good today?
Well, I'm glad me said that me looks good today
I was wondering if anyone was gonna say that me looks good, me
Thanks, me
No problem, me!
See you later, me!
If you know what I-
If you-
If me know what me mean, me!
If me- If-
Anyway.
*weird voice* Things are getting dangerous in here it's really bad for...
fUCK ME- ohh shit *laughing* god dammit you bastard.
Fuck these fish- AH! DON'T FUCK ME FISH- ohhohooo
Don't fuck these fish...
Bad advice... (No, Mark. Continue promoting beastiality. It's great.)
If I was being really finicy about this
and wanted to go for the highscore, you got to
get the things that are very close to your size
... but not too big
So you gotta like, judge it
because you get scores based on, uh
how big the fish is that
you eat. But you only grow bigger based on
the number of fish you've eaten,
so- oh god. Oh, oh no. Oh no, ooohhh that was dangerous...
... So was that but *voice getting gradually louder* I LIKE TO LIVE DANGEROUSLYYYY
Very dangerously...
I think I could have eaten that one... I can eat these...
Yeah... Not that one... Maybe that one...
That one? Yeah! I can eat that one.
*weird laugh thing*, the fuck.
I was- Even how I was going into that one...
I was not 100% sure about that.
Oooh... Yeah, so it's just- it's just quantity based for the size...
But! If you want to secure
ultumite vic-tor-y,
you gOT TO GET THE BIGGENS!
But I'm not- I'm not doing that...
I'm just saying, for you guys,
if you ever want to get the highscore on this.
Ooh, I can eat that guy
OH SHIT I'M GETTING BIG NOW (( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
It's getting serious...
Um... This guy, definitely.
Yeah, that guy, pro- Okay, I'm almost there.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah! Yeah, yeah. Uh, oh.
Oh shit. Uhh... That guy, actually!
HUOOOOOOHH THAT WAS CLOSE.
This guy? Yeah! This guy!
Okay!
Now we're getting there! Now we're getting it! Ooh...
Still, I don't think big blues, I don't think big blues just yet
hABADA HABADA... Okay... HABADA HABADA
Woah, habada. Woah, habada.
Not the biggest of the blues, yet.
But, I can get that guy.
Yeah!
Yes, I can!
*shouting* YES I CAN! YES I CAN!!
Oh, oh, I think we've... I think we've crossed a threshold.
I think we've crossed the ultimate threshold!
THE THRESHOLD OF AWESOME!
YES!
LITTLE FISHY IS NOT SO LITTLE ANYMOOORE
Little fishy has come to DESTROY
LITTLE FISHY IS GOING TO CONQUER THE OCEAN.
LITTLE FISHY IS HERE TO DISRUPT THE ECOSYSTEM.
LITTLE FISHY IS WIL- LITERALLY CAUSING THE END OF THE FISHY WORLD.
CAUSE I'M KIND OF A GREEDY BASTARD THAT'S JUST GOING TO EAT EVERYBODY AT THIS POINT
*sing-song voice* Oooh nobody bother fishyyy...
Little fishyyy's swimming in the seaaa...
Okay, yeah this is getting rid- this is pretty much to the point of ridiculousness, now,
But this is what happens when you play in fishy, I'm sorry my voice is going
Um, but this is what happens when you play Fishy. You eventually-
As something analogist, political bullshit or something I don't know economic... I don't know.
But, you eat a lot. You get bigger. You get so big that you just start eating everything.
Aaand nothing else can Suuuurvive! Isn't that lovely?
What a great way to end the entirety of the ocean.
God, little fishy got big!
Holy Shit.
Wow.
That's uh
Quite a fish.
I'll just- I'll just sit here now. I don't want to expend anymore energy. I'll just let them sail directly into my mouth.
I can't expect to be worked for my meat!
What?
I can't expect to work for my meat so I'm just going to wait for my meat to...
*mistakes have been made*
Anyway..
It's just like- It's just like my body just undulates and grabs fish in and pulls them into my skin directly
Just- *blub*
*blubbery fish noises*
*louder blubbery fish noises*
Oh, I just have to sweep up and down.
*speaking to fishes* Sorry, everybody!
Sorry!
I'm not sorry. I'm not sorry in the least.
...Not even remotely sorry.
Welp,
*Reads* You ate everything and completely destroyed the pond eco-system.
Well, then I get to move to the ocean and then everything gets to die out there!
But anyway,
I finally played the game that I've always talked about, this is Fishy.
I've sai- I don't know how many times that I've ever said this game, but it's a cool game. It's one of the-
earliest that I've ever played on new grounds and it's just fun!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching! You can try to beat my high score by clicking the link in the description below.
So thanks again and as always I will see YOU in the next video. Buh bye!
[cool outro music]